hello and welcome to this video playing
our penguin from the US mmm okay and so
I've got something sloth by
transposition I haven't played d4 yet
which makes them yeah we have some
interesting points it quick queen bee
three for example can be quite
interesting yeah iam what can play
without them a move deform and see how
black plays an interesting idea is an
early g4 and the team plays very much
focused on the queenside hmm plain g4
looks very funny and I can prepare it
maybe it's not exactly my style of play
but yeah I don't know this is kind of
interesting you took it took quite some
time to set up something here on the
queenside which is not so clear that it
helps them a lot ng5 this is kind of
kind of threatening the knight on f6 it
doesn't have any great great square to
go to go to sometimes they try 95 in
those situations but white can take and
go ad form this is really really really
dangerous now and then therefore I think
looks quite nice I mean if black takes
this this is fantastic so we has to go
back while
wow I thought this is that this is not
playable I mean what what about the dark
squares and my the Queen battery here
with g5 coming up oh this is hanging
about h4s hanging okay well it still
doesn't welcome now Chadli only has a
check there basically
okay so it's a funky position but it
should be good what is he going to play
maybe hmm now I was just about to say
this could be it could be an idea yeah
positioners it's a messy position g8
yeah well I can go g5g five is the most
aggressive move in a way but rook g8
okay then I have Queen to e5 i also have
d3 just attack the noid yeah maybe do
that it's assessor Canada the tough
position and not not exactly my kind of
my kind of game so let's see um actually
I the only thought about the other rook
Queen you five f6 Queen B 4 C 5 my queen
is trapped this is crazy oh wow that's
bad and what's pollution was fantastic
writing I can go to h seven though oh
I'm sorry I can go to htown it takes me
a long time to realize that but and
Knight f6 mmm might have six takes
cheeks and my Lucas hanging and then
then look aged 80 what is silly what
what a silly spot silly stuff okay I
know how unnecessary can you play it
does very unnecessary so these three was
rubbish em okay I mean there's still
some play left simply because the
position was so great before okay shakya
first check
yeah the bishop he is extremely strong
it's not that yeah i think this position
might be okay for white nothing of that
was of course planned but it might be
okay for white because the the bishop is
definitely not worse than his rook there
it controls the two possible entry
squares of course the king is is yeah
snot in such great shape here
I know he gets to inspect them okay I
can do this we have to that specially
five mate so that's not happening
bad man III is a little bit weak son ok
King b8 very likely the move he said
that's what I would and that's no
I go there and I can take f7 I don't
know that it's kind of interesting
before saw lots of interesting move okay
I don't have enough time to figure that
out check so if five is possible the
team look at five tho time morning
check very dangerous III is hanging this
is a bit of a shame so came check can I
somehow i'm probably not check it's
pretty probably a perpetual check check
grah I've heard jay drive yep so it is a
perpetual at the end to discern yeah
both sides were lucky in this game I
think his position out of the openings
basically losing after this this is just
this is not a playable position for
black I don't believe it but I screwed
it out very very quickly afterwards and
maybe you can even argue about Bishop
takes but Queen takes must be good yeah
this nerdy for looks a bit crazy shut
its it's maybe I'm the only move that
puts up something serious here at least
he has some some direct ideas and here I
have to improve somehow I mean this is
just terrible but totally mindless move
and that the tube took time for it so
the engine wants to check on you five it
only gives white 0.7 so it's not as at
least after a short calculation time
it's not as winning as I thought I
thought that this should be over one
okay it doesn't seem to be the case this
is what the engine gives the shine and
it's a pretty crazy line
check check and this is some better for
what yeah it is why okay I kind of it
seems that I who estimated it okay I
mean I when I when I said that I thought
here I didn't see that 94 um Queen age
forth stuff this probably means i have
to start with this and this is very good
yes spoon like this no now is this is
this is unbearable so so probably back
and now something like this white has a
fantastic advantage in space and the
Taking Chances King us much safer yeah
something like this so in the actual
game i played this this terrible d3 move
I was simply only looking at this and
now i have 25 course but he can do this
this I cannot play I mean I can but you
know here check the rook hangs and he
still has this thread so I decided to
give this up but where where engine
wants to take here
hmm and since I'm losing immediately
it's not a big surprise I mean it was
very much desperation I just don't quite
understand and the problem here that
probably that this isn't that clear oops
I'm sorry that this isn't that clear
because I now have this threat training
so it wants to check here if I could do
this now and takes things ah the queen
is also here ok ok I came here this is
stronger than check yeah and now things
are not clear at all yeah although the
engine gives me a clear advantage yeah
it was kind of it was turning around
this was not right ok this is the
correct move Queen age 4 look here and
here why was winning amazingly not okay
when the screen has no squid it cannot
move the tech probably is too strong I'm
attacking with everything and his pieces
are wrong the engine is not plus 4 so it
is a full window and now things are not
clear check ya mean no I know I'm
winning chef ok the problem is I
shouldn't give the check the check looks
good but it is actually not going this
is winning now because of course I'm
threatening an immediate made our this
is so simple you cannot take a letter
also i have this still end up in the
pocket ok shine what a shame and hear
the engines has black wins i can go to a
five or a very much I
so a very very questionable game I mean
it was kind of kind of clearly wavered
and Kim yeah okay so tons of chances for
both sides to win the games but simply
not taken okay well thanks for watching